out of everything that we love about
souls you know the law the characters
the combat I think that PvP is the thing
that they need to get right the most in
my opinion it's a vitally important part
of anyone's first playthrough and I
think that the game with the best pvp
system will be the one that everyone
plays even years after its release so
over the next 12 minutes I'm going to
run you through everything that the
network test has taught us about Dark
Souls 3s PvP
let's see where things are headed first
up let's talk about how you invade you
invade using the red eye orb item
similar to in Dark Souls 1 this item
lets you invade as many times as you
want Miyazaki has stated that players
will no longer be locked behind
consumable invasion items which is good
for encouraging invasions additionally
players now matched on soul level not
soul memory and finally I had really
fast invasions during the test so
everything's looking good on that front
everyone's biggest concern in the
network test was that you could only be
matched with hosts who had summoned help
meaning that most of your fights were
against multiple players most fights
involved teaming up with a red phantom
for victory
like you see here or it meant overcoming
multiple opponents all by yourselves
most of your fights were 1 versus 2 or 1
versus 3 or even 1 versus 4 which is
pretty brutal but the thing to remember
is that this was probably intentional
from software probably wanted to fill
these worlds with as many phantoms as
possible this is a network test they're
doing it to stress test their servers so
while I'm really scared that this
mechanic will remain and that invading
multiple opponents will become the norm
I want to believe that it's just a
feature of the network test so let's
hope for that players did adapt to this
system in the tests it was really common
to invade a Fight Club where you fought
one enemy at a time in a civil manner
while this panel of judges watched on
from above the dried finger item was
really useful after every invasion to
reset the invasion timer and as a result
constant PvP ensued if you're a red or
white phantom you appear in another
world with roughly 70% of your health
you also invade with half of your
remaining estes both reds and whites can
use Estus flasks to heal both health and
mana and it's interesting most fights in
Dark Souls 3 that were long and
drawn-out revolved around the efficient
use of these flasks because killing
other players actually rewarded you with
Estus so that you could continue
fighting killing an invader as a host
gives you three estes killing an invader
as a white phantom gives you one estes
and killing a white as an invader gives
you two estes so this does a lot to
encourage fights between the host and
the invading player encouraging the host
to ant down the invader if they're low
on health or mana and encouraging the
invading phantom to hunt down the white
phantoms until they can take out the
hosts alone it meant that invasions
lasted a long time and were fuelled by
constant battle take the two white
phantoms in this clip for example they
were kind enough to die so that I could
keep my health topped up and it let me
keep up that pressure until the host was
left alone and I still had all the estus
in the world speaking of healing
it's nearly instant now and almost twice
as fast to take effect as in previous
souls games however in Dark Souls 3
after your health comes back your
character stands still for a really long
time
meaning that yeah it's really easy to
get their health back if you need it but
it's also very easy to get hit after you
heal look at this guy he got hit way too
many times and he used his Estes really
inefficiently and I think he's just
realizing that I killed both of his
phantoms he ended up getting away from
me in the end and at first I was really
annoyed that he got away but now in
retrospect it's kind of funny because
now he has to fight the boss with no
phantoms and no health and no Estus so I
win I'm pretty happy with the way
healing is right now because it's
possible to defeat your opponent both by
overpowering them when they have estes
and even by backstabbing them if they
use their estes badly it's good to have
both options i think speaking of which
let's talk about back steps they're
usually a pretty controversial topic
everyone remembers the lag back stabs of
Dark Souls 1 everyone remembers missing
a backstab in Dark Souls 2 because you
had to punch them first
and well no one really remembers
backstabs in blood-borne PvP do they in
Dark Souls 3
I think they've finally figured out the
perfect backstab system in Dark Souls 3
the animation for back stabs is similar
to in Dark Souls 1 where it's quite
instant but it is also possible to whiff
a backstab and miss like in Dark Souls 2
if you're not positioned properly
the whiff animation has you perform the
backstab animation but without locking
your opponent into place see this clip
my backstab attempt still hits the enemy
as if it were a regular attack and he
doesn't get locked into place and back
stabs are a good mechanic they do
deserve to exist because there needs to
be something to punish players who leave
themselves exposed for example if your
opponent spans Perry you deserve to be
able to backstab them to counter it if
your opponent heals too close to you you
deserve to be able to punish them for
that
unlike in blood-borne Dark Souls 3s
backstabs allow you to do these things
but they aren't completely unfair like
in Dark Souls 1 where players could take
advantage of the bad netcode no longer
can you do running back steps no longer
can you really fish for back stabs and I
feel like I deserved all of the back
stabs I got which is a pretty good thing
in previous games simply by virtue of
back stabs existing certain strengths
weapons were just bad because it was
easier to backstab punish a slow weapon
well not this time
because slow weapons actually have
really really good tracking check out
these clips where I was using the great
sword my character can pivot along with
my target while I'm carrying out the
attack which is a huge buff to strength
weapons this increased control is a big
deal because strength weapons have
traditionally been really bad in PvP
because it's easy to punish them so I
reckon they're going to be more viable
this time around before the network
tests
I thought the charge attacks were going
to be really bad charge attacks are
charged up by holding down r2 and you
can release it for massive damage but
charge attacks really do benefit from
the improved tracking some weapons like
the battle axe even had charge attacks
that would carry your character far
forward and these attacks honed in to
whatever you were targeting so
they could close the gap in PvP and they
were a lot easier to aim than I thought
they would be moving on if you break an
opponent's guard you can perform a guard
break repost similar to in Dark Souls 2
you can do this by kicking them with
their shield up
you can deplete their stamina while they
have their shield up or you can use the
guard break attack for the short-sword
weapon art r1 I think it's really
important that players get significantly
punished for bad stamina management or
for just leaving their shield up when it
doesn't need to be this mechanic does
really help the depth of the PvP and
that short sword might just be my
favorite weapon so far it has a really
simple move set and it's weapon arts
give the weapon a depth and a
versatility that it's never really had
before and I was honestly surprised at
how much depth weapon arts added if you
don't know weapon arts are activated
with l2 and they give you access to new
powerful moves that consume mana souls
games have always revolved around the
weapon that you choose and I do think
that webinar to give that weapon more
character than ever before let's talk
poise the rule in the network test was
pretty much if you get hit by one attack
it's very likely that you'll get hit by
a follow-up attack before you can roll
away while most attacks will stagger
your character once there are certain
attacks that grant your character hyper
armor preventing you from getting
staggered the great sword for example
seems to have hyper armor during some of
its swings are particularly the webinar
which certainly makes you able to tank
any hit but this poise
it's definitely subject to change I mean
everything in the network test is
subject to change but we do know for a
fact that equipment load hasn't been
taken into account in this demo as every
character you played regardless of
whether it had heavy plate armor or
light cloth it was able to roll around
without any drawbacks to using heavy
armor so it is possible that armor and
poise simply wasn't a factor in this
test so maybe it's still being worked on
there's a long time till this game comes
out remember another interesting thing
is that poise can actually be granted to
you when you cast miracles guys this
makes me so excited for miracle based
characters and also magic based
characters because both miracles and
magic have
benefits that are granted to you when
you press l2 with a catalyst or a
talisman
so with miracles when you press l2
instead of l1 to cast your spell your
character is granted this yellow glow
and a ton of poise allowing you to cast
spells in your enemies face without fear
of being staggered now this does come at
the cost of a little bit more manner but
it's a very powerful tool with this you
could tank an enemy's melee hits while
casting lightning spear to do even more
damage or cast heal when you're in the
midst of battle with a bit more
confidence if more melee based miracles
are introduced
I expect the Paladin archetype to be a
really good force to be reckoned with in
regards to sorcery if you press l2 with
a catalyst equipped it grants a damaged
buff to all of your spell's for the next
10 seconds so I was really excited when
I played the academy assassin class I
found it to be the most versatile in the
network test soul greatsword was
fantastic for cutting down a group of
phantoms and switching between soul
arrow and sold art made it really easy
to get in some hits from a distance and
just chipping away at phantom health
which is really useful all of these
tools are really really useful when
you're fighting a group of enemies
because it gives you versatility which
is the most important thing sometimes
you have to attack from a distance when
they're engaging with other enemies and
having that control over the battle was
great I mean I didn't really like magic
in previous souls games in PvP but I
have high hopes that it's going to be
good in Dark Souls 3 there was a lot of
information to get across what do you
guys think of it all I'm looking forward
to reading your comments down below
personally I am cautiously optimistic I
really want this game to be a game that
I can PvP and for the next year or so
because blood-borne just didn't offer
that for me here's hoping they get it
right I sincerely hope that they do
the next video will be on PvE highlights
from the network test so if you weren't
lucky enough to get in let me run you
through it subscribe so you don't miss
it
and I'll see you when the next one guys
looking forward to covering this a bit
more Cheers